australia is so freaked out about the
spread of the rona
that
they
are you know telling people to take all
these precautions lock down don't go out
don't buy things
one animal shelter was so worried that
people would come adopt the rescue dogs
amid the surge of coronavirus
that they just shot all the dogs dead
they just
they just killed a bunch of puppies
to stop people from adopting the puppies
because if the people adopted the
puppies they would they would leave
their homes and interact with them
i'm not much of a dog person okay i
always consider myself a people person
not like a dog guy or a cat guy even i
know
that killing puppies
is pretty extreme and not not a great pr
look but that's mass hysteria that
you're seeing
this is there was a woman who tweeted
yesterday
who
said this doesn't even relate exactly to
coronavirus only tangentially she
tweeted out and said that
she can no longer speak to her son that
she and her son always had a great
relationship but her son voted for
donald trump and he's a conservative and
she doesn't even she doesn't understand
him anymore she doesn't even know him
anymore and she and i at first i thought
this was just a hoax but i'm beginning
to think it isn't a hoax it's this very
long tweet thread her saying i've been
crying for days and days but i had i
just had to cut him out of my life
completely i had to
because i can't because he voted for
trump and so he's bad and he's evil but
i miss i i hate this this is terrible
it's really stop sending me mean tweets
people this is so awful
i
i think this could be real i think this
is happening i think people are in the
grips
of a mass
hysteria
with their neurotic response to the
coronavirus with their neurotic response
to donald trump with their
neurotic with their neuroses generally
they
aren't i don't even i i don't mean this
as as if people all have these clinical
problems there's a social contagion
effect too
just as there is
such a
psychological condition as gender
dysphoria but there's a social contagion
whereby it spreads when people accept
these things the same is true for
neurosis the same is true for hysteria
people
are really
on edge why is that
because we don't have cohesion because
we don't have things that are settled
because we don't agree on anything we
don't even agree on the definition of
man and the definition of woman and so
when we've had this debate about
afghanistan does relate back to
afghanistan we've had this debate should
we project power in afghanistan should
we pull back the simple fact is if you
don't have cohesion at home if you don't
know what you stand for what you're
doing you can't project
strength abroad even if you want to
you you before you go
hold on slow down
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your podcasts type in let's just hear me
out type in
the michael knowles show
hit search
it comes up they're probably going to
bury the results but it'll you know
it'll come up eventually subscribe leave
a five star review maybe leave a comment
here on youtube before you leave
i would appreciate it greatly it'll help
us get around some of the big tech stuff
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you